welcome back everyone when the calendar
hits may tomorrow if you can believe it
also a time to celebrate asian pacific
american heritage month
the discovery children's museum is
celebrating all month long with special
performances
and some fun activities for the kids our
hector mejia live downtown right now
with a preview hey hector good morning
hey there alex good morning and so
there's a lot to celebrate the museum
here celebrating a lot of countries
including hawaii samoa japan
thailand and china and in a second
you'll see a musical performance but
right now we want to talk about the
activities happening throughout the
entire month of may here joining us live
we have sam
sam thanks for joining us again for an
early morning
live shot how you doing good good
morning and welcome to the museum
we're getting ready today for asian
pacific heritage month
at the museum so what are these hands-on
activities that we have planned for the
kids
so we have lots of different activities
for the whole month of may
we're going to be highlighting five
different countries
and traditional crafts and science
activities from each of those countries
which countries so we're going to be
doing japan thailand
china samoa and hawaii and there's also
an entire calendar dedicated it's about
a few days for each country or a whole
week
a whole week actually for each country
it'll start on a saturday and we'll get
a
performance or an artist workshop for
each country as well perfect said
segway talking about performances uh
tell us you know what we have right now
so this is gary he is um from hawaii and
he is going to be doing a musical for
musical performance for us with his wife
so this is just one of many performances
planned for the entire month that's
really neat
yeah definitely the five weeks of this
so cool
so uh lastly yeah tickets so tickets can
be purchased
online or at the front of the museum
entrance um you can re
reserve your tickets ahead of time
anytime thank you
all right well there you go reporting
live hector mejia and
gary here at the uh discovery children's
museum
8 news now back to you guys sounds great
hector and the music sounds good too the
dancing spectacular and
very good to uh honor and acknowledge
our
enormous asian population culture here
in the valley which is uh
everywhere you go pretty much we're the
ninth island absolutely we sure are
and it's always it's so colorful and the
music and the hula
i always i love that so much so so much
tradition rich tradition that
a lot of people don't even know so great
way to discover it yeah we listen to
that all morning with gary
it's so peaceful yeah beautiful